some movies are bombing right now
seems like every other week that there's
a major release that underperforms at
the box office and recently Disney have
had a string of blobs that have left the
company potentially losing close to a
billion when we close out this year
Elementals done terribly and now Indiana
Jones and the doll of Destinies open to
just 60 million dollars off the back of
what's at least a 300 million dollar
budget what exactly is going on right
now it's called capitalism well
throughout this video we're going to be
going through the key factors and
reasons as to why there's a lot of
things at play here that are stopping
films from doing very well obviously
there's a lot to talk about too so if
you have your own opinion on it then
drop it in the comment section below and
also make sure you hit thumbs up or down
if you agree or disagree with our
thoughts by the way I'm your host Paul
welcome to the heavy spoilers show now
let's get into the video
it's up top I think it's important to
say that you shouldn't judge a movie by
its box office there's a countless list
of films that have done terribly when it
comes to taking but they've been amazing
movies overall juxtaposing this there's
been some right turd sandwiches that
have made Michael Bay a lot of money and
all in all money doesn't make a movie
however Hollywood is a business as well
and with investors shareholders and an
industry relying on profit you have to
make money let's say you're a big
billionaire yeah and a studio company
you're looking for an investment if you
gave them even 10 million dollars yes
just 10 million dollars to go off and
make an Indiana Jones movie you wouldn't
want just 50 million back investors are
wanting major Returns on their
Investments and I think this in the
flash could have potentially killed off
the possibility of Studios going crazy
with their money first up I think we
need to talk about the facts of the
situation and what Indiana Jones and the
dial of Destiny brought in on its
opening weekend domestically in the US
the movie opened up to 60 million with
it taking in 70 million in overseas
markets coming in at 130 million dollars
worldwide that's less than half of the
crystal skulls opening back in 2008 that
opened at 272 million and adjusted for
inflation that's about 384 million in
today's money now we are noticing this
trend with Hollywood where so many
movies are struggling at the box office
and the first point I want to talk about
is a fool me once mentality this is kind
of the feeling the audience have in
general right now and we've hit a point
where there's been so many of these
sorts of Legacy sequels where people
have left disappointed that they almost
don't want to take the risk anymore now
lucasfilm especially has managed to
cause a lot of backlash with Star Wars
and this is due to the fact of how they
handle the sequel Trilogy I actually
thought the dial of Destiny was okay but
I I definitely don't think that it felt
like it was necessary Hollywood's greed
has led to them being creatively
bankrupt and every week's either a
sequel prequel or something that we've
seen before we're at a point now where
they've made the quote-unquote final
Indiana Jones film three times now and
people might just be worn out by the
whole idea out of the fact Jones isn't
exactly a hero that stayed in the
Zeitgeist and you can see why audience
interest wasn't that high now what I
mean by that is that Star Wars was
released roughly the same time as the
original Indiana Jones Trilogy was these
were big successes in the 80s and both
did big numbers when it came to George
Lucas oh that Star Wars has managed to
maintain an active fan base and this has
come with toys cons Comics books video
games expanded lore TV show and also
films Indiana Jones hasn't and though
it's had its odd piece of media drop
here and there it's not been this
consistent wave of content to keep
people hooked I think it's difficult to
expect the younger generation to God and
see an 80 year old hero when even 15
year olds today probably went alive when
his last movie came out and only what
Studios do now and they've got this
older hero is that they hire younger
actors with big followings but Phoebe
willowbridge hasn't really got a fan
base that's going to deliver big bucks
now there's also the fact that the last
film was widely disliked by most of the
fanbase I know there will be some people
out there who like it yeah but overall I
think we can all admit that General
sentiment towards it was that it was the
worst out of the franchise when a movie
does well then its sequel normally
follows suit and it has to be said that
the MCU has used this to great effect
Avengers Infinity war was of course a
massive movie and then end game dropped
to an opening of over 1 billion Batman
Begins wasn't a crazy hit but people
enjoyed it on DVD so much that by the
time the sequel came round we all were
on board into the spider-verse did okay
but across the spider versus where the
numbers have really come in and you can
find these examples in Hollywood
everywhere you look and the reason that
I'm bringing this up is that the
opposite is often true of movies that
don't do well if a film lets people down
then its sequel tends to underperform no
matter how good that people think it is
now kind of jumping back to DVDs I think
that Hollywood have stupidly eliminated
what used to be one of their big earners
back in the day a lot of movies could
tank at the box office but then the
physical media Market is where Studios
would recoup if a film bombed but it was
popular on VHS or dvd then in the end it
didn't really matter I'm a big collector
of 4K Blu-rays but the Market's almost
non-existent now and streaming in
digital have completely killed it off
recently we've seen in some cases where
a movie does bad at the box office and
then it gets released on streaming just
three weeks later sometimes though even
if it does okay they still go that route
and to me all it's gonna do is change
people's behaviors for example both
Creed and Evil Dead release just weeks
after showing in cinemas and they were
announcers going digital just the
weekend after I was gearing up and
getting ready to go see them second
weekend yeah cause I missed that first
one due to being busy however when I saw
that I could just wait another weekend
see it at home sure enough I just
watched the films then nowadays we know
that movies come to digital really
quickly and streaming services tend to
have a 45-day window the films that
don't do this I.E Avatar and Top Gun
they had success for months just being
in the theaters now I know that not
every movie is gonna be that big and
Studios just want to recoup as much
money as they can after that opening
weekend drop off however I think overall
this is altered people's habits and once
again fool me wants shame on you fool me
twice I'll just wait for it to drop
digitally in three weeks cheers mate now
Pixar especially have suffered because
of this and they're now seen as a
streaming Studio which has killed their
movies there's also just a general
dislike towards Disney as a brand these
days you only have to throw a like on
this video and then go to your home tab
to see what I'm guessing is going to be
filled with anti-disney videos and also
Auntie Kathleen Kennedy ones now even if
this was just 10 of the audience that's
still enough to harm the box office by
tens of millions the is also a massive
culture war going on right now that
Disney have placed themselves in and
whether you think that's a good or a bad
thing it's always going to come with a
cost now I was weighing up whether to
bring this up in the video or not as it
can be a touchy subject but I think if
we're analyzing this to the best of our
abilities then it has to be seen as a
factor even if it's a minuscule one it's
still a factor and it might knock tens
of millions off the box office if it
comes in a play a Studios like Paramount
in Universal have kept themselves out of
this culture war and so far they've done
well by not getting involved again how
you come down on that entirely up to you
but let's admit it's gonna come with a
cost that costs these films money now
Kathleen Kenny is arguably the most
disliked exec in any fan base right now
don't quote me on this but I'm sure the
dislike button on YouTube itself got
removed after she did some speech that
got millions of downvotes on it there
just seems to be an aura of discontent
around here which is came off the back
of how she handled the sequel Trilogy
this this got met with a lot of backlash
and there's so many projects that
lucasfilm have now shelved because of
poor mismanagement there's been
countless Star Wars movies announced
with up-and-coming directors that have
then been shelled once a director's
popularity wanes off often put down a
creative differences it seems like
complete mismanagement on the Studio's
behalf Josh trank D Ryan Johnson Paddy
Jenkins and so on they've all had Star
Wars films announced that have either
been canceled or quietly shuffled off
the Slate same thing will probably
happen with James Mangold 2 where they
announce a movie with them once a
director's seen as an ex-best thing and
then when the next project releases it
causes issues with the studios I'm
telling you yeah that tiger Woody Star
Wars movie and never getting made anyway
Kathleen seen as being bad for the brand
and it definitely feels like a section
of the fan base that'll just boycott
anything that's involved with it there
has been a lot of talk about how she
could get fired off the back of this but
I've heard that the room had thousands
of times before and I guess we'll see
her contract actually Runs Out in 2024
so they might just let her have some
dignity and ride that out but I think if
he stays at the studio then they're
gonna run into more problems
unfortunately what tends to happen in
these situations is that it's a little
guys at supper and we normally get
layoffs lower down the chain rather than
at the top when I worked in shops and
still not saying it's the same thing but
when I've worked in shops and stuff yeah
and we hit a point where there was no
profit it's always been Janine on the
till who gets a minimum wage that gets
fired instead of the bosses who run the
business into the ground I think that
will be the case here too and it will
probably be those lower down the line
that get hit now you have exceeded your
video rate limit and must now join the
channel as a member to see any more of
the video I'm just kidding it would have
been a social commentary there I love
you now on top of Kathleen Kennedy we
also have another member of the creative
team that could have caused issues you
might remember the elements of the film
apparently leaked last year and then
James mangle got into it with people
online look mate I totally get it like
I'll get people talking crap about me
yeah if you if you can't believe it but
I don't think it ever gives you any
positive publicity to go and engage with
it all it does is cause a negative Aura
around your film when you have headlines
that thrive off drama rather than the
film itself I've argued with people
online and then the next day I've woken
up and regretted it because in the end
it doesn't do anything to benefit you
now doubt that this had a major major
effect on the box office but even a
little one is enough to cost a couple
million basically yeah the point I'm
trying to get across in this video is
that there's lots of different reasons
why the film didn't do well and all
these coming together make for an
underperformer now let's say you don't
exactly have a lot of positivity around
your studio and you want to build some
hype right well you're screener for
people to get some good word of mouth
both Indie and the Flash did this but in
the case of both we saw how it backfired
flash was shown at Cinema con early on
the air and Indiana Jones dropped a
Cannes Film Festival the former got
Goodwood of mouth whereas the latter
didn't and Indie really struggled to bat
off those negative First reviews now I
don't want to say them people are cans
or snobs yeah but I don't know if a film
like this would have ever done well
there them guys I like to watch black
and white silent movies made in 1912 so
the new old man CGI Face movie it was
always gonna struggle either way though
I think showing it this early didn't
help either as they both had to try and
maintain the hype for weeks and weeks
and weeks when the buzz online dies down
because so many have already seen it
it's difficult for General audiences to
feel like they should care there's very
much his idea of well everyone's seen it
I'm not it comes out on digital soon I
can probably wait another week again
this ties back into a earlier point and
you had the idea that the theatrical
experience isn't that necessary those
negative reviews clouded the film for
weeks and again it was another bad move
by Kathleen Kennedy plus yeah the movie
it's not really a feel-good story I
think a lot of people wanted Indy to go
out in a place of story and instead what
we get is a film about a saddle man that
takes away from him more than it gives
the Final Act you know I was thinking
like ah they're gonna have the final
Indiana Jones Adventure it'll be a big
swing he'll save the day it'll be a
bombast again to this cinematic Legend
instead though what we get is him
getting knocked out and then waking up
three days later with no idea what
happened you sat there asking like how
did they all fit in that little plane
and questioning the time travel instead
of seeing what should be Indie at his
best so the word of mouth around this
wasn't there to sell it to others
because there wasn't the idea that this
was the last hurray even now I don't
feel like that ending feels like the
final Indiana Jones film and from the
guy who made Logan I was expecting more
I think we definitely have to talk about
the state of the world in general and
how it's left a lot of movies with very
little chance so one of the main reasons
that the budget's so high on this is due
to the fact that it was filmed during
the pandemic production was constantly
stopping and stuff starting and with it
being a worldwide film you had different
rules in different countries some things
were delayed testing added a lot and you
had several different factors here
racking up the money the budget spiraled
out of control and you've now hit a
point where they have to make a billion
just to break even we've also gone from
the pandemic into a cost of living
crisis and people just don't have the
money to go see films every week if
you're taking a whole family out it can
rack up a lot and if it's that or just
waiting three weeks most will choose a
ladder now on top of this all the
Studios have a backlog of films where
they've not been able to push things out
to audience capacity because of this
thoroughly seeing everything now whilst
they can and it seems like we've got a
big film almost every week it's very
oversaturated and difficult for a movie
to stand out and when you've got a
sequel to an old franchise it's
difficult to feel new and fresh so it
kinda gets lost amongst things like
across the spider-verse which even five
weeks in is still doing really well I
think in the end though these guys just
spent way too much and this is something
that was seen in the flash too 300
million dollars is difficult to justify
and a film like this was always gonna be
impossible to profit from if you're
overspending under deliver then you're
gonna be left at a loss and it's
something at Disney don't seem to want
to learn from I do think that this is a
film that will change the industry
though and that will probably get more
conservative amounts when they're green
lighting their pictures what it really
comes down to though is making good
business decisions and a movie like this
was always gonna struggle whether it was
the state of the industry with their
straightest streaming methods or the
fact that audiences have been let down
so much in the past the switch away from
physical media is us just moving with
the times but it also hurts the back end
profits that these films make the poor
leadership and depressing nature to the
movie was hampered by mixed reviews that
didn't capture young audiences interest
and therefore didn't capture money in
the end there was just so much riding
against it and given all these reasons
this is why this movie failed obviously
there's a lot we've gone over here and
if you agree or not then let me know
below think stuff like this can be a big
learning curve and I'm sure there's lots
I can learn from you guys as well so
make sure you leave a comment if you
want to support the channel for as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below and as a
thank you you'll get early access to
videos every week you also have our
merch store over at shopzeroedition.com
which sells lots of nerdy inspired
t-shirts hats and more you just launched
a secret Invasion slash Pulp Fiction
inspired t-shirt so if you want to head
over then help us out and the links in
the description now if you want
something else to watch we've got a full
breakdown of the movie's ending and
giving our general thoughts on how we
felt about it there's lots of things to
talk about I know people are gonna have
a lot to say so yeah definitely head
over there right after this by the way
huge thank you for singing through the
video I've been poor I'll see you next
time you take care peace